we will continue our phone number is 6 1
7 8 30 for 750 we have our next caller
up who's on the line and where you
calling from um my name is Gail marido
i'm calling from strand pennsylvania um
I was just wondering uh what your
thoughts were there are a lot of uh
rumor circulating internet right now
about Bernie Sanders maybe being
threatened by the Hillary camp uh
something about a gaseous sheet during
yet democrat uh convention yeah and how
he's not really campaigning for people
our revolution i just want to know if
you thought there was any truth to it i
have read articles suggesting this thing
about like you said Hillary Clinton has
threatened Bernie not not personally
shouldn't show up and say listen Bernie
but that there was some kind of threat
communicated I I have not reported on it
because I did not find that it met the
rigor the the sort of journalistic rigor
at this point to say hey this is even
just asking these questions feels like
sort of necessary to me at this time but
since you've broached it I think it's
absolutely fine to discuss it uh I don't
at this point find the articles i've
read convincing in any way whatsoever i
think it's a purely circumstantial case
instead terms of olean really been
campaigning etcetera etcetera gash on
the cheek so far and I don't say this is
an ad hominem but it has sort of like an
alex jones feel to me uh but i am not
ignoring the story in any way and if at
some point I feel like there's really
something to report I will I me where
you on the story um I'm not really
believing it though I do find it kind of
strange that Bernie Sanders would be
like campaigning for the his uh the
candidates he's endorsed and the whole
debacle with our evolution I don't think
he's been like physically threatened I
think that the Hillary camp just kind of
told him you know stay away yeah I said
well you know I mean are sort of like
what's implied in in Bernie not
campaigning for the down ballot
candidates that he endorsed is that by
campaigning for them it might somehow
hurt Hillary I mean you sort of have to
draw that parallel to figure out how you
could put together a theory that that
supports this and those voters that go
out to vote
for those Bernie Sanders and Dorsey's
they're not gonna vote for Trump I mean
some of them might vote for Jill Stein I
don't think it'll be a significant
enough percentage to affect Hillary
Clinton so I just don't even buy the
oftentimes with these theories we have
motive and and and sort of motive alone
that we can imagine i'm not even finding
the motive to be very strong here i
don't even know why anyone would have to
threaten Bernie to prevent him from
campaigning for those down ballot
candidates because I just don't think
it'll hurt Hillary really or all right
thank you so much for the call uh